good morning al dan I you know watch you
show morph through the years it's been
great years ago I would you know call in
and we'd be talking about app control
and maybe man to man outside zone
underneath and now I wake up this
morning and you're cooking a lot of meat
and you're talking about Jeff Bezos his
divorce very very eclectic I'm just so
friendly just a well-rounded man than I
am but you wouldn't be into our meat
Friday on meat Wednesday today because
we have hot dogs and we have chicken and
when's the last time you had a hot dog
yesterday no I think it was maybe maybe
Monday no they have hot dogs at the at
the club at the golf club okay very very
good chicken I like chicken to remember
it's just it's just vegetables it's
vegetables and it's mushrooms and it's
onions that are verboten everything else
is you know fish is good okay great
steak is terrific and or that wonderful
steak we had from Toscana when I visited
the studio in Los Angeles we'll do that
again I hope we can read we preach that
hopefully in the next couple of months
do you go you know I'm well-rounded do
you cook do I cook I used to barbecue I
would throw a steak on the barbecue
that's about as far as I would go but my
wife won't have to brush it potato in
the in the oven and that's about as far
as we look in fact we may even do that
tonight all right let me start with the
important stuff the Cris Collinsworth
slide into the frame into the picture to
start the broadcast when did this become
a phenomenon I think about maybe a month
or six weeks ago and somebody brought it
up to me and then more and more people
brought it up and I guess it became a
big deal you know on social media and
the internet and all of that I was not
aware of it you know by going to the
internet that people were telling me
about it then I had to go and see what
it was about and so we decided we would
have a little bit of fun I think was the
game in Los Angeles it was the Eagles
and the Rams week 13 or 14 out here the
Coliseum and we figured out you know
what let's let's
a little fun with this will acknowledge
it so we even thought at one point what
I would do is I would turn to my left
and then Chris would sneak in from the
right and I'd turned around as if I was
surprised but that was overdoing it so
all we did was bring him in from the
right side let the folks out there know
hey we're with you we get what's going
on rolling this together let's have a
lot of fun but I didn't know if he was
sliding in or your camera was just
widening out so it gave the appearance
that Chris was sliding in or is it a
combo it's a combo platter okay you know
most of those booths that we do the the
on cameras from are very small they're
very very tight Chris you know really
has to sit next to me but to get out of
the initial shot when I'm coming on and
you know laying out the groundwork for
the game and what you know the the big
stories are it and then bring Kristin
for the analysis so what he has to do is
is lean out at about a you know maybe a
45 to 55 degree angle so his torso is
closer to mine not on camera but the
shoulders in the head are you know at a
45 degree angle to the outside and then
he kind of comes he comes angling and
let's put it that way how often do you
bite your tongue on saying something
critical about the officials you know
the one thing about the officials this
is a very hard game to officiate I mean
it's really it's insane to think that an
official can see everything you've got
22 fairly massive bodies colliding on
every play and these guys is supposed to
you know detect every single move move
and and and get it right the first time
and the only time I really get
frustrated is when the the announcements
don't tell you what happened and I guess
that was you know my frustration from
time to time you know through the years
hey what happened we're trying to figure
this out we kind of know the rulebook we
now have Terry McCauley in there as well
thank God who you know a longtime
official to kind of parse through
through everything and you just want to
know at the end of the play what was the
deal what's what is
the rule what tell me what the rule is
and you know through the years we found
a lot of you know a lot of fischels are
good some are much better than others
but you know I do understand that this
is a this is the toughest game to
officiate by far so you know you want to
give them as much leeway as you can but
you do want to know at the end of the
day at the end of the play what's the
call tell me tell me what the rule is
and why you've interpreted it the way
you have living in Los Angeles can you
explain to us why Los Angeles has
embraced the Rams far more than the
Chargers well the Rams were here for a
number of years and most of the people
that you know the right grew up with
around here when I went to high school
and the Rams were here and the Chargers
had started here but in the American
Football League which nobody was really
paying a lot of attention to in 1960
they were here one year and then they
went to San Diego so they were never Los
Angeles's team they were saying the
aygos team between 61 and a couple of
years ago the Rams were part of the the
fabric here and we even showed it on the
game this year Dan where I'm gonna write
the first time I ever went to the
Coliseum you go back to 1958 I'm just a
kid I just moved out here they're
playing the Chicago Bears the crowd was
100,000 comma 470 100,000 470 great game
rammus 140 135 Southern California is
40% larger now than it was then so when
people say oh you know can the Rams fill
the stadium I'm going wait a minute if
you draw a hundred thousand in 1958
can't get 75,000
I don't understand the math so that's
why the Rams you know and the Rams got
back here first you know they had a year
head start on the Chargers the Rams are
playing in the an iconic stadium even
though it's under construction right now
it doesn't look very good at the moment
and the Chargers are playing in a soccer
stadium which holds about 28 or 29
thousand people so that is why you know
the ramp it's kind of like Lakers
Clippers sort of like you know Dodgers
Angels its Kings against the Ducks the
other teams may have some success but
still I mean it's going it's always
going to be the
it's always gonna be the Lakers always
and I mean it's like Chicago - you look
at Chicago
the fact is the people forget everybody
who remembers the Cubs winning the World
Series a couple of years ago wow you
know it's 18 million so they wanted the
White Sox wanted yeah about 12 years ago
does anybody talk about the fact the
White Sox wanted so it's like Chicago -
it's always gonna be Cubs one White Sox
do the same thing out here it'll always
be Rams one Chargers - but the Chargers
are making some inroads right now they
win on Sunday all those sudden there'll
be a lot of buzz around here you have
the game on Saturday between the the
Chiefs and the Colts and you have to
marquee quarterbacks here obviously you
know Andrew Luck being back but it is
there a subplot that you're looking to
emerge here or preparing for it to
emerge in this game I think one of the
most interesting matchups is going to be
that Colt defense which has gotten so
much better this Darius Leonard is
something he's the the linebacker should
win Defensive Rookie of the Year Kenny
more on the backend they've got some
good players
we saw them against Tennessee watch them
now evolve
you've got luck playing great you know
at the beginning of the year nobody into
a fans would look through a football and
he started out fairly slowly and they
were one in five and they lost to the
Jets and they look terrible and they got
the offense together and Marlon Mac has
turned into a you know a really good
running back and we know about T why
hilt and he's been there for years but
on the other side of the ball I think
they've done a tremendous job and Matty
broke loose you know they get a head
coaching job at some point because of
the job he has done as the defensive
coordinator so I see in the Colts I mean
it's pretty it's it's an amazing story
in many ways a lot of credit goes to
Chris Ballard the general manager I mean
he took some chances in the draft he
built that offensive line that Quentin
Nelson is a monster I mean and I said it
on the air and we had the Tennessee game
you picked a guard yeah number one
nobody is too excited about it because
the an offensive guard is the least
glamorous position in football the fans
want you to drift you know running back
if you need a quarterback obviously a
quarterback a people somebody you know a
Joey Bosa maybe somebody like that the
pass rush
nobody's gonna get excited about a guard
but you you isolate this guy on tape and
everything Wow
and they've done I think Babbage done a
fantastic job the best thing that
happens them of course is Andrew lock
you know doing what he's doing
but I think you know that we know but
with the Chiefs offenses it's great they
can run up 60 points but that inde
defense is much better right now than
it's been and I think that's going to be
a heck of a matchup what's the most
surprising game that you've ever called
with the outcome of you didn't see that
happening oh man there's so many of them
I mean I think that you know I'm just
thinking about the believe it or not the
Rams Titans Super Bowl back after the 99
season and it wasn't the first half was
pretty boring I think it was 9 nothing
ramsden took a 16 nothing lead it looks
like the game was over
and Jeff Fisher rallied the troops on
the sidelines the Tennessee the Titans
coach at that point tied the game with
two minutes to go so wow you know here
we are in the name Isaac Bruce caught a
touchdown pass right after the
two-minute warning from Kurt Warner that
was the year that the Rams came out of
nowhere and all of a sudden the greatest
show on turf evolved from the four and
twelve season and he had Warner and Fork
and you know Isaac Bruce and Torrey home
over that and then the tightness came
back and and and got it all the way down
the field and the game ended on the
one-yard line with a great tackle by
Mike Jones on Kevin Dyson so I mean that
was gay I wouldn't say that was the most
surprising game it was as exciting as
any game I can remember and just to have
it evolve that way and then that way you
know it's so funny damage you're always
thinking about the wackiest things you
know or the most recent and there were a
few wacky or thick games and we've been
in Chicago the other day I mean what can
I tell you everybody saw it
everybody's talking about it you know
Chris something up perfectly the double
doink ending the game so you know
through the years have been somebody
like them I think about 800 NFL games
now kind of you know premium postseason
and all of that so some of them run
together but you know you remember the
fantastic endings who's done more NFL
games than you I don't think anybody
probably because I've done this with 30
three years 33 season started in 86 on
Monday night went over the NBC and OH
so we've done about I don't know 20
some-odd games a year plus playoffs plus
so I think I'm in the 700s for sure at
that point I don't know I don't thinking
I don't know that anybody's done anymore
maybe I know Pat summer when I walk with
Frank Gifford did it for 27 years so
Frank you know several hundred but I
can't think of anybody who's done it for
33 well hopefully you continue doing it
a long time there he'll I don't know you
know we we don't do this with
broadcasters like we do with athletes
like you know we we keep trying to push
Brady out the door it seems like you
know like you get to a certain age where
like any time for you to retire
thankfully we don't do that to us
I know I hope you don't come on you know
what I gotta tell you something I love
it as much as I ever have maybe more
because I know you know I'm but closer
to the end of the career in the
beginning I get that but I draw such
inspiration from people like Vin Scully
you know Benny was 88 and he was still
great my man Marv Alberts still going
strong brent musburger you look at these
guys they get Murray did it for a long
time and I think I told you once I went
through a Bruce Springsteen concert a
couple of years ago I had never seen him
and he's running around the stage for
three hours and 40 minutes doesn't take
a break it's crowd-surfed he's all over
the place playing the hell out of every
song and I'm thinking to myself I'm
walking out of a sports arena that night
going you know what this guy just did
this for three hours and 40 minutes at
the age of whatever he was at that point
66 or 67 he's done this he's going to do
it again in two nights and he's gonna do
it again in two more nights I think I
could do a few football games I really
do
after watching Springsteen so I draw my
inspiration from that yeah you're just
sitting there in a comfy seat talking I
mean that's I mean it's not too
demanding people screaming at you you
know it's adrenaline banned because it's
exciting and you doing stuff on the fly
and it's all why but you know the
greatest thing about this job there's no
second take
so once in a while you're gonna say
something you wish you could you know
pull back I get it I mean you know I
think you can't dispense 18 gazillion
words and I'll have a few pumps and I've
had them and my career I get it but it's
so much rental izing to be there and to
think you know hey you got to be so
sharp razor sharp and I don't know that
those three hours the synapses of my
brain open up very wide and then at the
end of the game I go back to go and you
know who's my next-door neighbor
have fun in Kansas City al thanks for
joining us as always safe travels you
too daddy bun for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]